[Music]
in a disappointing contrast to its
stellar pixel drunk series cue games
latest downloadable PlayStation
exclusive the tomorrow children is a
bland monotonous inscrutable mess that
locks you into a tedious time draining
loop the game consists primarily of
resource gathering and city building
with some floaty platforming and clumsy
combat in-between but none of these
constituent parts feel satisfying on
their own and together they never amount
to a larger payoff to make matters worse
the game's opening tutorial doesn't
really explain what you're supposed to
do in tomorrow children let alone how or
why instead it covers only the absolute
basics following a failed global
experiment all the remains of our world
is the void a vast empty space dotted
with disconnected towns a handful of
marauding monsters and resource-rich
islands that randomly appear in the
nothingness your character is one of an
army of identical projections that serve
as the worker drones of the Soviet
themed society each projection is
controlled by another human player for
some reason you'll only catch brief
ethereal glimpses of other players
rather than simply playing alongside
them at all times but you'll feel their
presence as your resource counts
fluctuate and new buildings pop up in
your shared town resource gathering
constitutes the single largest portion
of the moment-to-moment gameplay but
every single step in the process is
excruciatingly ly tedious first you must
travel from your town to the one
available island at that moment which
means waiting for the bus you cannot
call the bus as it runs on a preset
schedule and there is only one bus if
you wander up as it's pulling away too
bad and once you board the bus you
cannot skip the ride if you hate
unskipable cutscenesthat's
once you actually reach the island you
can start to break it's odd destructible
environments down into resources
unfortunately with the basic pickaxe you
hit a button once then wait is your
projection hammers away and a meter
slowly fills it's painful you can use
real cash to purchase a black-market
pickaxe that is according to the menu
text 15 point 5 times faster than the
basic pickaxe but be warned all tools
even those for purchase tools break over
time once you uncover some raw materials
you have to drag each block back to the
bus stop using a backpack that contains
just three pockets for resources which
obviously results in endless unavoidable
backtracking that is utterly mindless
and repetitive then you have to wait for
the bus to return before manually
hauling all the resources from the
original bus stop to their individual
piles further into town yet another
tiresome empty process that could have
been easily automated the islands
themselves can be visually intriguing
and even fun to explore but that's
nowhere near enough to compensate for
the mind-numbing time devouring resource
collection loop of course all that
resource gathering is in service of the
games other major gameplay pillar
crafting if the city building portion of
tomorrow children was brilliant and
rewarding maybe just maybe all that
tedious mining and moving and piling
would feel worthwhile unfortunately it's
not at all basically every town you
could possibly find yourself in will
already have most of its essential
infrastructure so at best you'll need to
add a power plant or maybe a new
apartment complex or a turret the
crafting table simply doesn't offer many
options that are actually worth building
which stymies any strategy that might
have emerged from this portion of the
game plus you're always at the mercy of
the islands which may not provide the
resources you need outside of crafting
towns also team with civics related
stats & gameplay systems but none of
these ancillary systems seem to have any
material impact on the experience
elections leveling perks my towns
technology rating their menus explained
the numerical implications of each one
but I never actually felt that impact
while playing the game
I also never felt attached to my town in
any way
remember in tomorrow children you're
building a town with online strangers
with whom you cannot communicate as a
result towns develop haphazard layouts
that are difficult to navigate much less
take pride in if nothing else tomorrow
children's style is certainly novel from
its creepy doll face characters to its
patriotic propaganda the game certainly
makes the most of its chosen motif
unfortunately that motif is much cooler
on paper than in practice after hearing
the same Soviet March blare at me from a
teleprompter for the hundredth time I
was more than ready to leave that world
forever I simply did not want to spend
time there it also didn't help that the
game suffers from persistent noticeable
technical problems but frankly poor
collision detection is the least of
tomorrow children's troubles the
individual components aren't enjoyable
on their own and they don't contribute
to anything bigger
there is no payoff there is no point and
I'm happy to be done playing it
[Music]
by travelpod member
[Music]